Mathematical morphology has this huge
science behind it that's a very abstract
algebra because in some sense,
it's all about set theory.
Right?
I mean, basically,
that's what you're doing.
You've got these binary sets, and then
you do these operations on sets, and
then there's gray level morphology.
You won't find much of it in
the computer vision literature anymore.
When I say computer vision,
I mean conferences that use the word
computer vision in their title,
like computer vision pattern
recognition, European conference on
computer vision, the international
conference on computer vision.
You won't find a lot of things,
people doing work on morphology.
But if you go to certain, pattern
analysis kinds of things where they're
doing syntactic operations, you'll still
find mathematics of that, being done.
However, even though it doesn't appear
in this computer vision research,
we use it all the time.
Because we use it to
clean up our results.
In order to be able to get those great
results that we can brag about to our
our, our colleagues, or
to get paid by industrial folks to
build systems that actually work.
So I think of think of this as not sexy,
but very important.
I had a whole bunch of jokes to follow
that and I couldn't use any of them.
So I'll just say that,
it's kind like me.
All right.
Talk to you later.